bonsoir dr emmanuelli merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france avoir des
parents qui ont déjà annoncé qu'ils ne
remettraient pas leurs enfants à l'école
malgré les menaces de sanction du
gouvernement à ce que vous en tant que
médecin vous comprenez ses choix si oui
j'ai discuté aujourd'hui avec deux mères
de famille qui était confronté
objectivement à cette situation est ce
qu'elle me disait c'est que elle
souhaite avant tout qu'il y ait de la
cohérence est ce que reproche
aujourd'hui un petit peu les parents
d'élèves
c'est parfois les messages
contradictoires et le manque de
cohérence parfois dans les mesures qui
sont prises par exemple une mère de
famille me citer l'exemple d'un grand
lycée à barcelone où les classes étaient
bien divisés en groupe avec pour chaque
groupe des bracelets de couleur
différente
et puis tout d'un coup à la sortie du
lycée des milliers d'élèves qui se
retrouvaient agrégé ensemble à la sortie
d'école sans aucune distanciation et
donc avec effectivement un point
d'interrogation sur la cohérence des
mesures qui sont prises
effectivement au niveau des
établissements on nous a pourtant rabat
cher son nom justement des médecins vos
confrères des pédiatres hammam une
tribune dans un quotidien de médecins
que les enfants n'étaient pas vecteur de
ce virus est ce que ce postulat est
toujours d'actualité
c'est vrai qu'on a encore toujours
beaucoup d'incertitudes c'est à dire que
effectivement on voit bien aujourd'hui
qu'on assiste à une vague de
contamination importante avec un taux de
mortalité inférieur mais personne n'est
capable aujourd'hui d'expliquer pourquoi
on a cette nouvelle configuration
épidémiologique et probablement comme
dans toute épidémie on off on est face à
un phénomène vivant et probablement les
choses évoluent et peut-être qu'à un
moment les enfants peuvent ne pas être
vecteurs de l'épidémie est un autre
moment
d'autres circonstances parce que
l'environnement change devenir devenir
un vecteur d'épidémie donc c'est très
difficile d'avoir des positions
extrêmement tranché scientifiquement au
stade où on en est de la connaissance de
l'épidémie ça veut dire qu'on est
finalement un présent que ça soit en
france ou en espagne selon vous de
rouvrir les écoles quel est le point de
vue du médecin comment aurait-on pu
faire autrement
non sans doute pas il faut continuer à
vivre il faut avancer et il faut avancer
avec les connaissances tel quel
telle qu'elle est ce qu'on va dire telle
qu elle se perfectionne effectivement
avec le temps et avec les données donc
non cette rentrée était nécessaire
simplement effectivement ce qui est
perturbant pour la population c'est de
ne pas pouvoir avoir je dirais un
discours qui soit scientifiquement
parfaitement clair mais c'est en raison
effectivement du manque de connaissances
qu'on a aujourd'hui des tenants et des
aboutissants cette épidémie la situation
préoccupe également les évidemment les
enseignants qui ont déjà annoncé qu'ils
feront grève tente neuf mille
professeurs sont recherchés pour
permettre de reprendre les cours dans de
bonnes conditions notamment en catalogne
et en galice est ce que ça vous semble
atteignable comme objectif vous
comprenez en tout cas c'est ses
professeurs oui c'est vrai que les
professeurs ils sont en première ligne
dans cette affaire il se retrouve
effectivement dans des dans des
environnements et des configurations
qu'on peut qualifier quand même malgré
toi risque puisqu'ils sont en
collectivité et c'est vrai que moi je
peux comprendre qu'il y est
une part de craintes pour autant nous
sommes face aujourd'hui effectivement à
une épidémie inédite et il faut tous
ensemble avancer en essayant
effectivement de d'appliquer les mesures
qui nous sont dictées pour faire face à
cette épidémie
aujourd'hui clairement tant que comme
médecin en espagne vous parleriez
clairement de deuxième vague on c'est
une première vague qui ne s'est jamais
arrêté vous êtes inquiet alors c'est pas
moi qui en parlent mais aujourd'hui un
des grands hôpitaux universitaires de
barcelone l'hôpital jean mane trias a
publié une étude sur les perspectives de
l'épidémie en espagne en europe et
eux-mêmes par le début de deuxième vague
et il parle même il utilise même cette
expression de canari dans la mine de
charbon
vous savez que votre foi dans les mines
de charbon les mineurs avaient un canari
pour je dirais détecter la présence le
risque d'un coup de grisou parce que le
canari mourey est aujourd'hui les
chercheurs disent mais les canaris c'est
l'espagne nous sommes le canari de
l'europe
et si effectivement les choses
s'aggravent ici eh bien on pourra dire
qu'une seconde vague va déferler sur
toute l'europe
effectivement l'espagne le pays le plus
touché d'europe après avoir dépassé les
500 mille cas comment vous expliquer
justement cette entrevue les
spécificités espagnol alors là aussi les
chercheurs ont publié une étude il ya
deux ou trois jours et eu effectivement
symbolisée ça en appelant sa le trident
de l'espagne avec trois dents qui
explique 7,7 effectivement cette
caractéristique espagnol la première
dent et bien c'est le mode de
convivialité les bars les restaurants la
deuxième dans c'est effectivement la
faiblesse du réseau de dépistage et la
troisième dans c'est effectivement le
relâchement dans la mobilité qui a eu
lieu plus tôt en espagne que dans
d'autres pays européens entre les
différentes communautés espagnoles
merci philippe emmanuel médecins
français exerçant en espagne d'avoir été
avec nous